Today's gonna be
the first of a two-part video
showing how to make
a person-safe set of bow and arrows
that you can use to
play tag with your friends.
[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
For this project, we're using some
3/4 inch schedule 40 conduit PVC.
It's almost exactly
the same as the white PVC,
but since this is
not designed to be buried,
it's more sunlight resistant.
These fiberglass driveway markers
are designed to stab into the ground
to give yourself a little additional
visibility for the edge of a driveway,
usually.
Here's the basic idea.
Some fiberglass rods
will be cut to length,
secured together,
and fit inside a length of PVC 2.
A paracord bowstring
will then be fit into some notches,
carved into the ends of the PVC.
Let's start by taking our PVC pipe,
and cutting it to 5 feet in length.
[Music]
Overall, we're going to want
four fiberglass rods in our bow.
One will be just under 60 inches,
one will be 48 inches,
and two of them will be 24 inches.
Our whole PVC pipe is about 5 feet long,
and our longest fiberglass rod,
we want to be about
1 inch short of either end.
So, let's take 2 inches off,
and they get 58 inches long.
When cutting fiberglass,
you want to make sure
you're cutting slowly and carefully,
so you don't get a lot of splintering.
To help reduce splintering even further,
I'm going to wrap our fiberglass
in a piece of duct tape before I cut it.
We've got two driveway markers
that are 48 inches long.
That's just the right size for one of them,
the other one we need to
cut nicely in half.
[Music]
After cutting that in half,
we now have our 5-foot length,
our 4 -foot length and two 2-foot lengths.
Make sure it's got the
centers of these all lined up.
We now want to use
a little bit of duct tape
to tape around the very center,
and hold all these rods together.
[Music]
These four fiberglass rods
bound  together
are what's going to give
our bow it's spring power.
Now, when we pull against our PVC,
instead of just bending in half,
It should arch nicely,
and give our string some spring.
The four rods should fit
fairly snugly down inside the tube,
and right where they're taped together,
there should be enough friction
that it doesn't slide unless you push it.
We've got a nice flexible rod
with a lot of spring to it,
and what we need to
do now is add a string.
Our PVC isn't going to do a very good job
of holding onto any bowstring right now.
I'm going to try to file a
shape about like this.
So, let's take a round file,
and carve some angled
notches into the top and bottom
that our string can grip on to.
With this shape,
when our bow is curved,
that should be pretty much
in line with the direction of the string.
[Music]
We need to tie two knots in our string,
so that the loops on both ends
will hold securely,
but not have so much slack that the bow
straightens out when we're not using it.
Let's fold our paracord over,
and use a Figure-eight knot
to make a loop that will be strong,
and large enough to fit
over the top of our PVC.
[Music]
By attaching the string onto
one side of the bow and bending it,
we're able to mark approximately
where on the paracord
we want the other loop to go.
This is not necessarily
going to be exactly the right spot
because after attaching
our string to our bow,
the stretching action may
make it a little bit too loose,
and it may tighten up the knots more,
giving a little more slack into our string.
But we'll start with this,
and adjust from there.
[Music]
Not bad. Not bad at all.
Let's just trim up the extra paracord,
and we should be able
to give our bow a test fire.
We have approximately 57 inches
between one end of our bow and the other,
Let's just mark right
on the center on the string
that will let us know where
to be putting the knock of our arrows.
We're going to be going over how to make
these person-safe arrows in our next video,
but for now I'm just going
to take one and see how it fires.
[Music]
Beautiful.
Great hang time.
Our bow and arrow is
always working great.
I do just want to add a little
bit of decoration on to this
because you know, we like
adding decoration to stuff.
I'm not going to put anything
right where I'm gripping
because I feel like that would
just get worn off over time.
But I think the rest of the bow,
I'll try and add a little bit of color to it.
[Music]
Our bow is built,
and it is working great.
We've got incredible range.
I think I can shoot
these arrows like 100 feet.
A quick note about the bow,
if you leave it strung all the time,
the PVC and the fiberglass rods
inside will start to bend,
and then, you'll lose a lot of power.
So, anytime you're not actively using it,
you should take the bow string off.
In our next video,
we're going to be showing
you how to make these arrows,
so they are safe and they can't hit you,
even if they hit you in to face.
The goal is so that no matter how
you shoot someone with these arrows,
they're going to be fine.
Guys, we've got more for you to see.
That little box at the top will
transport you directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The box at the bottom will show you
what YouTube thinks
you should be watching now.
This bomb in the middle
wiil subscribe to the channel,
so you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see the next one.
Talk to you then.